what does always have something to look
forward to mean
i want people to take the reins of their
own life like a horse and point it in
the direction that they want it to go
you know what i mean if you want to go
east you have to go like this and go
east so
that was another thing my father gave me
he said josh you always have something
to look forward to
and it's very important because it it
helps you to believe that you are
creating your own life
you know
i'm going to
we talked a little bit about the
artist's way and they have an artist's
date and that you take yourself on an
artist state and i remember being
involved in the artist's way and i loved
it
but i was terrible at getting the
artist's date in because we're you know
this is going to call my attention and
that's going to call my attention and i
have to be
at this appointment and
and we busy ourselves out of
the artist state
so to always have something to look
forward to is part of
being responsibility taking
responsibility for your own joy
it's very important that we
take responsibility for our own
vibration if you're a creator
creativity and joy go hand in hand there
is a school of thinking
that is you know the more pain or the
tortured and stuff you know all these
artists are you know great artists are
tortured people i i just don't don't buy
it i find it an indulgence
i believe joy and creativity go hand in
hand
so we're responsible for for creating
that in in as in teaching in my classes
my students will tell you you know
they get morose and they come to class
and they're like you know
so hard and auditions and you know
there's no jobs and now they make you
you know film yourself and you know they
just
walls of complaints
and
it's some of them have been around
for 20 or 30 years and they're tired of
the industry and they have a whole
nother level of complaints and i asked
them things like you know when is the
last time you took a day in nature
you know when is the last time you did
something fun when do you plan thing you
know so i make them make joy lists i
literally make them with this one guys
so do you have to go and
next class bring me 10 things that bring
joy you like doing them you know
and he came back he had one he had one
thing
on the list golf and i went okay golf
great
next week two more you know and he kind
of pulled himself up and when you do
those things when you look forward to
you know turned out he liked the
softball
you know so he went into a softball
league and he played in a couple of
games and he came out and he was like
you know that's his jam man that made
him happy you know
uh you know i'm not i'm far from a
pollyanna
but
you're responsible for your own
happiness so when you first you have to
know what you like make a joy list
because you can't put things in the
future if you don't if you're not
looking forward to them you know it's
not something you love that's going to
bring you joy so first make a joy list
if need be and then you put those things
on the calendar three times a week
why not you know people go one or to
stay forget one order state it's your
life
put things on your calendar to look
forward to that you want to do you want
to go to europe you don't have any money
say yourself i'm going to europe in a
year and two months
in the
october of the la la year i'm going to
and where am i going to go and get
specific just like artists just like
actors you have to get specific i'm
going to france where are you going in
france well
research that i'm going to these two
places in france great where are you
going to stay
and when you start getting specific just
like you create a part that's just like
creating a part where are you you know
where
where are you going to stay all those
kinds of questions are the same kinds of
questions that artists and actors ask
you answer all those questions you put
the date on the calendar you start a
little savings fund and you know what
sorry to seem airy fairy but the
universe is going to contribute to that
because you are now operating at a
higher vibration and that's where
inspiration comes in
sure and on the flip side not to be
tumorous but it can
work that way in the negative absolutely
absolutely if you when you constantly
worry
you will attract
things that will contribute
it's really benevolent though it's
really like oh did you want to worry
okay let me help you out with that you
know it's there's no
good bad or indifferent about it it just
is you know
uh and if you complain then you'll find
more things to complain about you know
we're so complainy and meanwhile we're
so blessed we really i have to say to my
husband all the time
we're complaining we're complaining
about ridiculousness here we're
complaining about who's gonna cook the
salmon tonight you know what i mean
it's like let's we have salmon let's
cook it let's celebrate
you i think you said in the book that uh
some of your students
they think there's a career that they
want but really it's someone's career
that's already out there and they're and
they're in a sense emulating that but
they need one that's true for them
yes yeah there was you know i have
students that um
and i think it's natural you know
they're very taken with
you know she's a singer she wants to be
madonna you know he's an actor he wants
to be james franco or they they see
these people it's a little bit of a love
affair because there's a lot of
admiration that goes on in the arts
and certainly in acting and so you know
they they
fantasize
what it would be like
to be this person
and there's nothing wrong with fantasy
but it's not going to get you what you
want
your dream
your dream
is not fantasy when you can see yourself
in the picture you know
madonna for instance that's a very clear
concept of her career
she had to have seen it she saw the
costume she saw the hair she saw the
makeup she saw the voice she saw a
presentation marilyn monroe the same
thing
so it's just a tiny shift over to
what is that for you what is that for
you if you want to be that kind of actor
which is to create a whole kind of an
image thing there are different kinds of
actors
you know there's cary grant actors and
marilyn monroe this is a personality
that you kind of create for yourself
that sells that's a little old-fashioned
and then their character actors who have
a
much broader um
what does that call arc of of who they
can play and and some of them can you
know we never recognize them
every time we see them because that's
their goal is they want to enter so far
into character that we don't recognize
them
but when they're really good they're
still tethered they're still tethered
they never release once you release
it becomes acty you know you're playing
at something but when you loan your
heartbeat your breath your nervous
system to an entirely different
character who
you know then you tweak the nervous
system and it's a little bit different
and you tweak the energy this one has
lots of energy this one is tired or
exhausted or ill but you're still
tethered in on that energy line it's as
if this character's energy where you're
lying you're feeding it does that make
sense i think so yeah so do you think
most people want to be the persona or
there's some that definitely want to be
there they want to be the persona they
want to be admired because we're living
in a really narcissistic society right
now and narcissists don't admire each
other they don't you know they're not
necessarily kind they're all of their
attention their thinking is on
themselves so we're in a very
thinking
society
not a being society not energetic being
society but a thinking society and
that's why i talk about meditation so
much because
you know i was just talking to a car a
guy who drove me in a car and i was
talking about you just have that little
separation
because he was telling me you know like
i get cranky and i don't know my family
and i go you know can you just look at
it just look at it if you can what
meditation gives you even if you do it
five minutes a day it gives you the
understanding that you can step outside
your thinking
which is all
sorry ego it's not we we can't do
without ego we have to have ego it's not
a terrible thing it's just out of
balance you know we're just like all
about ego and thinking but if you can
step out a little bit just like that
much you can look
and see
oh i'm thinking this or i'm behaving
that way or
you know i'd like to change this you
know i had
i
i get cranky sometimes over i'm not
going to get into why but you know we're
all imperfect
and i was getting very cranky with my
husband we were working together and
sometimes i'm cranky when we're working
together we're writing together oh no it
doesn't go that way
and
he's such a beautiful human being and
suddenly i took a little step out of
myself and looked at myself and went
she's really jocelyn do you have to
carry on like this this is kind of mean
and abusive and why are you doing it and
so i looked at my husband just because i
could make that little separation and
said you know i'm really being a [ __ ]
aren't i
and he was so loving and dear and looked
at me and said
can can you
can you help it can you just step out of
it and go well i've stepped out that's
about as far as i can go right now
but then we laughed
so
what was the question well is it almost
like an outer body experience so there's
the charac there's the persona actor
which when they walk in
um you know all eyes are on them and
then there's it sounds like there's the
chameleon who can really become almost
another person yeah and and i think the
question was uh do most actors want to
um become the idea like if i just
absolutely adore kate blanchette yeah
and and want to become yes everything
that she does and i realize wait a
minute i'm wanting to emulate her i'm
not trying to be the best
me the apples and oranges type of thing
it's it's all from the same question
it's why i wrote the book there's no
connection to self
there's no connection to self so as a
teacher you know i could say to them
you're fantasizing what do you want for
you
what is your career do you want because
they also along with that fantasizing of
being king blanchett or any one of them
you want their career so you want a
movie you want to be a movie star
you know people don't think about
theater as much people don't think about
television they don't think about
creating their own movies make your own
movies you know what is it that you want
to do
because nobody's asked them that so you
have to be asked and you have to
continue to ask until what happens boom
boom boom something happened only you
can answer that question and only you
can answer that question with your own
nervous system you know with your own
responses so really what we need is
because
we need to lead people back to
themselves in their own point of view
and their own autonomy because even with
the chameleon actors
often they're acting out of unhappiness
they're trying to escape themselves and
so they can do this magic trick of
really entering but they're not very
happy as people i'm for like you know
let's let's let's have a little fun in
life because we're not here very long
and
i want to set an example i want people
to set an example that
this can be fun because right now it's
really dark
and one last thing if i may before we
move on and that is if i and i'm using
let's say the kate blanchet analogy but
what if that's not my type what if i
want to be that type but my type when i
walk into a casting office is someone
completely different and so i'm trying
to become an orange when i'm really an
apple
how do i reconcile that with myself as
an actor right
first you have to check on the heartbeat
is it do you really want to be kate
blanchett do you really want to play
those parts or are you fantastic are you
wishing you looked differently
um
and if you really want to play those
parts you can find a way
you know there was a
model
i grew up you know i was a really bad
model but that's another story um but i
worked with some around some very good
models and you know twiggy was a big
deal
eyelashes and stuff we looked sort of
alike but there was a woman named
penelope tree
who was a model and she didn't really
have the face of a model and but she
wanted it she had a heartbeat for it it
was a real thing for her so she created
a face with kabuki she made a white face
with very extreme makeup
and she wore very uh
geodesic kind of narcissistic geometric
clothes and she had poses that no one
had ever seen like you know she was very
just odd strange
uh poses she created her own thing
she was a huge hit why because it came
from her imagination like madonna you
know it came out of her imagination she
saw it you have to be able to see
yourself in it
um if it's not from your own heart
you're never going to get there here's
another example i'm not going to mention
her name but
you know i trained with a beautiful
actress i love this woman who wanted to
be capelin she wanted to be a movie star
and she was never going to be a movie
star she was you know from kind of coal
mining she was salt of the earth
babe
that sort of was recognizable to all of
us
and my teacher
who was milton gotzelos
he was he was very hard on people i
don't believe in being that hard either
but
he was very hard on her and
he kept telling her you know you're not
going to play these parts you're not
going to stop doing scenes from these
parts because you're not going to play
these parts you're salted the earth and
finally he said
he he hit home with her maybe it was the
sixth critique maybe the tenth critique
and he looked at her and he said
is anamanyani not good enough for you
and she didn't know who ana manyani was
and so she went and she looked up
onomanyani and she realized what he was
talking about and she realized the
wealth
of parts available to her as a character
actress and she's
getting goosebumps she started working
and she hasn't stopped since she's in
everything
she's in everything so it is finding but
it had to ring in her heart she'd look
at anamagnani and go
oh
i feel it i see myself in it you have to
see yourself in it